just a couple of hours ago late this
afternoon the new york times ran a story
saying that florida congressman matt
gates is under federal
investigation for playing some role in
sex
trafficking and potentially having a
relationship with a 17 year old girl
they're very
few details in major news outlets
tonight about this story we have no
background
on it all and not even any very informed
questions
instead we've invited congressman gates
on the show to respond to these stories
and give us his view of them congressman
thanks so much for coming on i
appreciate it
um so this is obviously a serious
allegation
tell us what the truth is from your
perspective
it is a horrible allegation and it is a
lie the new york times is running a
story that i have
traveled with a 17 year old woman and
that is verifiably false people can look
at my travel records and see
that that is not the case what is
happening is an extortion of me and my
family involving a former department of
justice official
on march 16th my father got a text
message demanding a meeting
wherein a person demanded 25 million
dollars
in exchange for making horrible sex
trafficking allegations
against me go away our family was so
troubled by that
we went to the local fbi and the fbi and
the department of justice were so
concerned about this
attempted extortion of a member of
congress that they asked my dad to wear
a wire
which he did with the former department
of justice official
tonight i am demanding that the
department of justice and the fbi
release the audio recordings that were
made under their supervision
and at their direction which will prove
my innocence
and that will show that these
allegations aren't true
they're merely intended to try to bleed
my family out of money
and this former department of justice
official tomorrow
was supposed to be contacted by my
father so that specific
instructions could be given regarding
the wiring of 4.5 million dollars
as a down payment on this bribe i don't
think it's a coincidence
that tonight somehow the new york times
is leaking this information smearing me
and ruining the investigation that would
likely result in
one of the former colleagues of the
current doj
being brought to justice for trying to
extort me and my family
so a couple of obvious questions that
come to mind and again just to restate
this just happened
don't have any other information beyond
what we've already said and you have
said
who first of all who is this department
of justice former employee who's trying
to extort the money from you
you say his name is david mcgee he was
a top official in the leadership in the
northern district of florida as a
prosecutor he currently works
at the begs and lane law firm as a
matter of fact
one of the recordings that was made at
the fbi and department of justice
request
occurred at that law firm and the money
that was supposed to be paid
today that would have shown even more
evidence
of david mcgee's work in this extortion
scheme
that was foiled by the new york times
story and i believe that's why
this uh this horrible information and
these terrible allegations
have been used this evening so
you're and i'll get the investigation in
a sec but but you're saying that david
mcgee
was motivated by greed he was trying to
extort money from your family that's his
motivation
you're saying i know that there was a
demand for money
in exchange for a commitment that he
could
make this investigation go away along
with his co-conspirators
they even claimed to have specific
connections inside the biden white house
now
i don't know if that's true they were
promising that joe biden would pardon me
obviously i don't need a pardon i'm not
seeking a pardon
i have not done anything improper or
wrong but what i am troubled by
is the real motivation for all of this
you know just tonight
ted lew a democrat is calling on me to
be removed from the house judiciary
committee
and i believe we are in an era of our
politics now tucker where people
are smeared to try to take them out of
the conversation i'm not the only person
on screen right now
who's been falsely accused of a terrible
sex act
you were accused of something that you
did not do and so you know what this
feels like
you know the pain it can bring to your
family and you know how it just puts
people on defense when you're accused of
something
so salacious and awful but it did not
happen it is not true
and the fact that it is the basis of
this attempt to extort my family
tells a lot and if the fbi and
department of justice will release
the tapes that they are in possession of
the american people will see what is
really going on
you just referred to a mentally ill
viewer who accused me of a sex crime
20 years ago um and of course it was it
was not sure i never met the person um
but
but i i do agree with you that being
accused falsely is one of the worst
things that can happen
and you do see it a lot let's go back to
the investigation you
you say that it was uh that it was or
is underway there wasn't investigation
what is the basis of that investigation
what is the allegation is that really
not very clear from these news stories
yeah again i only know what i've read in
the new york times
i can say that actually you and i went
to dinner about two years ago your wife
was there and
i brought a friend of mine you'll
remember her and she was actually
threatened by the fbi told that if she
wouldn't cop to the fact that somehow
i was involved in some pay-for-play
scheme uh that
she could face trouble and so i do
believe that there are people at the
department of justice
who are trying to smear me uh you know
providing for
flights uh and hotel rooms for people
that you're dating who are of legal age
is not a crime uh and i'm just troubled
that the lack of any sort of legitimate
investigation into me would then permute
would then convert
into this extortion attempt i i don't
remember the the woman you're speaking
of or the context at all honestly but
i i would like to know who so they're
saying there is a 17 year old girl
who uh you had a relationship with is
that true and who are they who is this
girl
what are they talking about the new york
times the person doesn't exist i have
not had a relationship
with a 17 year old that is totally false
the allegation
as i read it in the new york times is
that i've traveled with some 17 year old
in some relationship
that is false and records will bear that
out to be false
how how long has this investigation been
going on
do you know i i don't know
when were you first informed of it uh
you know again i i
i really saw this as a deeply
troubling challenge for my family on
march 16th when people were you know
talking about a minor and that they were
pictures of me with
child prostitutes that's obviously false
there will be no such pictures because
no such thing happened
but really on march 16th was when this
got going from the extortion standpoint
so what what happens next i mean you can
see there is this investigation i guess
a criminal investigation i'm not quite
sure the sex trafficking part comes in i
don't again for the fifth time i don't
really understand
the story very well but where does it go
from here i mean you're you've made an
allegation against someone by name on
the air and accused him
of trying to extort millions of dollars
from your family what
what happens tomorrow well what was
supposed to happen uh was the
transfer of this money that would have
implicated the former colleague of these
current doj
officials but that's obviously not going
to happen tomorrow
because the new york times story was
leaked in order to quell that
investigative effort so here's what
needs to happen next
the fbi and the department of justice
must release the tapes
that are in their possession that were
done at their direction
those tapes will show that i am innocent
and that the whole concept of
sex charges against me was really just a
way to try to bleed my family out of
money
and probably smear my name because i am
a well-known
outspoken conservative and i guess
that's out of style in a lot of parts of
the country right now
matt gates i appreciate you coming on
tonight thanks for giving me the chance
to tell the truth
i appreciate it it's a more interesting
and complicated story than
that i knew from reading about thank you
very much
gates interview that was one of the
weirdest interviews i've ever conducted
that story
just appeared in the news a couple of
hours ago
and on the certainty that there's always
more than you read in the newspaper we
immediately called matt gates and asked
him to come on and
tell us more which is you saw he did
i don't think that clarified much but it
certainly showed this is a deeply
interesting story and we'll be
we'll be following it don't quite
understand it but we'll bring you more
when we find out